crisis talks at the prime minister's
office in colombo a 10-member delegation
from the international monetary fund is
in sri lanka to discuss a bailout
package it's the greatest crisis that we
have ever had since independence
and the precursor to this is it's about
30 due to misfortune and 70 due to
mismanagement
so it's a mother of all crisis and
if not for the imf there's really no
other safety net that can save us
there's no money to import food medicine
fuel or cooking gas people have
struggled with shortages for months but
things have got worse and sri lankans
have run out of patience
this senior policeman was filmed
assaulting motorists who were demanding
fuel
army personnel fired into the air on at
least two other occasions
and in this incident protesters turned
on a vip vehicle that had jumped the
fuel queue
on monday police arrested 21 people
demonstrating outside the finance
ministry for obstruction
they said it had delayed senior
officials attending meetings with the
imf delegation
if approved the rescue package will be
sri lanka's 17th bailout from the
institution
this is self-inflicted
so we have excess demand
and we have had excessively low fiscal
and monetary policy that has led to this
destabilization
so the discussion with the imf are the
parameters
that sri lanka has to put in place for
us to go back to a stable position the
situation is dire schools have been
closed for two weeks and public servants
have been asked to work from home
analysts say imf funding is a
double-edged sword for sri lanka as it
may be the lifeline the country
desperately needs to prevent economic
collapse but will come at a price higher
taxes an end to subsidies and other
austerity measures mina fernandez al
jazeera colombo